The Event Horizon Telescope is a project
that we've been working on for many many
years to take the first picture of a
black hole and we've done it.
It seems impossible: how do you take a picture of
something that's shrouded by nature's
ultimate cloaking device? What happens is
the black hole's gravity is so intense
that all the gas and dust that's
attracted to it has to get into
increasingly smaller and smaller volumes
and just as your hands heat up when you
rub them together through friction, all
that gas heats up to hundreds of
billions of degrees. Everything around
the black hole is ultra luminous; in fact
central black holes in the centers of
galaxies can outshine all the starlight
from all the stars in the entire galaxy
and that provides this three-dimensional
flashlight around the geometry that's
warped by the black hole itself, so as
all that light is lensed around the black
hole onto what we call the last photon
orbit, it forms a ring; and that ring, the
shape and size of it, fall right out from
Einstein's field equations. It required
creating an array of telescopes that
spread over the entire globe, acting
together to synthesize an earth-sized
telescope and to be able to peer down to
the black hole itself required doing
this at higher frequencies than ever
been achieved before. It's required
recording petabytes of data. Those
recordings have to be brought back
together to a central location where
they're compared. We do all the timing
afterwards in a supercomputer and all
that technology really has come about in
the past ten to five years or so. So to
have something here where we're able to
see in a picture something that's
been predicted now for about a
hundred years, and immediately connect it
to a theory and immediately
make constraints that no one's ever been
able to make before and that is just,
it's incredible.
ultimately when you ask yourself what an
iconic image is it's something that
reveals to you something that you didn't
know before and it scares you a little
bit an image of a black hole captures
visually a one way exit from our
universe. We think about monsters they're
under our bed or you know they're in
caves and when you see something like
this you realize that they're really
monsters out there. The fact that we've
captured this I think is not just for
our team but for all of humanity.